hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the magnets Invitational is
Game two between Hikaru Nakamura and
Magnus Carlsen and Nakamura lost Game
one so now he needs a win to get back
into the match this is game 2 he Cornell
with the white pieces let's see let's
see what happens here
so he Carl opens with d4 and Magnus
replies with Knight to f6 with c4 e6
Knight to f3 and d5 Magnus just goes for
the Queens gambit declined with Knight
to c3 and the Bishop to e7 Bishop the f4
by Hikaru and Magnus just castles with
e3 preparing to develop the light square
Bishop and Knight B to d7 now and here C
5 by Hikaru and Magnus immediately goes
after the dark square Bishop which
Hikaru ignores Bishop to d3 this has all
been played before we have captures
captures now he gets an IC 5 square for
his Knight b6 by Magnus and here are
just before this isn't one of those
situations where you can go c6 because
black will just win that pawn I'd if I
defended Bishop here you'll pick up the
night and then win win your pawn so
instead before and now we have the usual
a5 a3 going after the pawn and only now
c6 we have castles by Hikaru and Bishop
to e6 now wanting to trade off the light
square Bishop the Queen to e2 and we
have a trade here captures captures and
here there is one game in the database
where Queen to c7 was played but here we
have g6 by Magnus and it is as of move
14 that we have a completely new game so
let's see how he Caro deals with this he
goes rook F the c1 and okay it does make
sense we have Queen to c7 by Magnus
developing the Queen connecting rooks
also going after the f4 pawn Hikaru
defends it with the g3 and here a
character son b4 with a captures and
queen back the b7 now we have route 8
the b1 not interested in trading Brooks
and the Magnus takes this opportunity to
double up rocks and the Alpha while also
grabbing a lot of activities so rook to
a3 we have Queen back to c2 not allowing
the night they remain pinned and rook F
the a8 now just grabbing more activity
for the rooks and the Kingi - now this
knife can move so this night doesn't
hang we have
to f6 by Magnus now putting pressure on
this point is well and now Knight to e2
the defending the the the d4 pawn once
again and now looked a - putting
pressure on both the Queen and the night
we have Queen to d1 now Magnus pushed
all of his pieces on the back rank and
now B captures on c5 b characters and
queen h6 now with a double attack on he
Cara's night on e - we've worked to see
- defending while also offering a trade
of one pair of rooks and Magnus trades
here we have rook captures Queen
captures and now rook to b8 cross and
offers another another trade we have
rook address and b8 Knight captures nb8
and now Knight to c1 they're getting the
denied back into the game
we have Knight back to d7 by Magnus and
now Knights to d3 now both of the
Knights can can come to e5 we have Queen
tabby five by Magnus and now just Queen
to c3 now adding another defender here
while also preparing some Queen to a
three to a seven or a 8 depending on
what Magnus place
Magnus goes for h5 and here Queen to a3
and here he car will really spent a lot
of time deciding on what to do here as
you have to take a lot of things things
into account like 9595 Queen goes here
what what happens with the night it will
you have problems defending the DF 7
point as both the Knights from i-5 and
g5 can cannot go after the f7 pawn so
Magnus had really spent some time here
to decipher this one
he went for King to g7 and now Knight d2
e5 by Hikaru problem is Magnus would be
very happy to trade off night for a
night however if you if you do this then
after F captures the bishop doesn't
really have a good square for to go to
if you move the bishop then Queen a7
attacks it or if a bishop went here
Queen to AAA it attacks it and after the
bishop moves now just Queen to d7 and
it's it's uh well just a winning
position for white the Queen Easter
guarding this pawn knife the g5 is
coming you're gonna pressure f7 and
black will not be able to hold this so
here Magnus is forced the capture with
the bishop which he does Bishop captures
on e5 and we have F captures now we have
Queen to e2 now if the knight moves you
can have some Queen to e4 check action
now Knight to g5 by hikaru immediately
going for the strongest idea now the
threat is Queen to a7 which will put
pressure on the night end on the f7 pawn
so Magnus finds a very nice way way to
deal with this Queen to g4 now of course
this Knight is hanging so Hikaru defends
it with h4 and now Knight to the f8 now
the kicker is saying okay if you go for
Queen to a7 then I have Queen f5 and if
Queen to c7 let's say going after the
pawn here with with two threats then I
have this very tricky night to h7 this
is the idea behind night to f8 Magnus
found it very nicely and now if Knight
characteris with the idea of picking up
the pawn later now Queenie for just
insurance Magnus a perpetual for after
king h2 are gonna go Queen e2 with the
threat of grabbing here which will
ensure your perpetual and after you
defender just win back to e4 check and
wherever the king goes you will have a
perpetual so instead after this night to
f8 by Magnus Hikaru goes for Queen to d3
he doesn't mind he doesn't mind a queen
trade here Magnus goes for a queen trade
and Hikaru just grabs it so Queen f5 and
Queen captures on f5 with he captures on
f5 and now King f3 by Hikaru
we have f6 forcing a trade here we have
e cap press on f6 King captures on f6
and now just kinked III and here the
problem for Magnus is that he's down to
one minute on the clock whereas Hikaru
has over 5 minutes on the clock and here
we have Knight to d7 Knight to d7 is not
not the greatest move however you have
to play something and here Hikaru has a
way of well pretty much ending this game
on the spot so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this idea but I
warn you it's not easy to spot so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that you can
put black in almost a complete to Swan
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's f4 now f4 makes it a
very problematic for for black to do
anything point is if you try if you play
it doesn't matter let's say you move the
knight
tonight it doesn't really have any good
moves now you go Knight f3 and you're
going to e5 which will put pressure on
g6 and c6 so let's say you shift the
king over there now you get nice to e5
and you can no longer defend both this
and this because the pawn prevents the
king from reaching this square and the
knight prevents the King from reaching
this square sure you're just gonna lose
this pawn on the other hand after f4 if
you move the King let's the King to e7
now you just get still Knight to f3 and
after King to d8 you're gonna get Knight
to e5 King to c7 yes you defend this
pawn now but you're gonna lose this pawn
and if instead you go for a trade Knight
captures F captures then the problem is
after King is 7 you've now created a
space for your King to infiltrate King
e6 are gonna go here King g7 but now
just King h6 and next move whatever
black plays can be 7 you're gonna
capture this you're gonna capture this
this and win the game so f4 is is really
a beauty that ends the game however
Hikaru first goes for Knight to f3 and
this kind of gives Magnus a chance to
solidify Magnus goes for King to e6 and
now Knights the e1 by Hikaru
we have Knight back to be 8 by Magnus
but now Hikaru goes for night to d3 we
have King to f6 and only now f4 so
pretty much we get the exact same setup
with Hikaru getting his knight to d3
instead of just jumping here from f3 but
okay Knight back to d7 by Magnus and now
Knight to e5 putting pressure here and
here and again yeah like I said if you
capture then just F captures on e5
creates this path for the White King it
will be completely lost for Magnus so
Magnus tries night to f8 but now he will
lose this pawn so Knight captures and c6
and now Magnus has to try and hold this
being upon down King e6 we have Knight
back the e5 pressuring this point that
means crossings Knight cannot move King
to e7 in out king to d3 now Hikaru plans
to shift the King all the way to the
Queen side and then or even try to Queen
the C pawn so King d8 we have King to c3
King to c7 now comes Knight back to D 3
which means Carlsen can start getting
his knight back into the game
Knights the b4 now putting pressure on
this point and Knight to f6 now
defending with King to b3 and now
King Tubby 7 we have King to a four and
now Knight to e4 they are trading this
point for this point you don't really
you don't really have an option you have
to play something Nakamura grabs this
pawn and the magnet scrap captures the
g3 pawn but now Nakamura has two
connected passed pawns and that will be
hard to deal with king b5 we have a
knight back to e4 but now just see sex
with check King to c8 and now King Tubby
six now we have Knight to d6 in here
Nakamura played nice the e7 check and it
was in this position on mu 57 that
Magnus calls and resigned the game which
means that Nakamura is back in the match
immediately equalizing and I imagine
feeling very good about himself so here
you resign because if you move the King
this way then just c7 check in here and
now you win the knight or if the knight
moves you just Queen the pawn and if you
go the other way after the check if King
here it's not much different you're just
gonna go Knight character sin g6 and
just go here and well just win the game
and the window the other pawns doesn't
really matter what what black plays sir
after this Knight to e7 check Magnus
resigns and like I said Nakamura is back
in the match we'll see what happens in
game 3 so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Melvin
Jones sebastian bombs and niels wild
Carl Nielsen and Blair Barnes for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Magnus Invitational until it finishes so
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday